welcome to pi data global 2021
uh we're here with saw one of our many
many amazing multi-talented data
scientists and uh
i'd like to
and i'd like to cut
and since this is his time i'd like to
just cut straight to uh
handing the mic off to him
you you can like you can take off
all right
well i'm sorry guys and um so this is my
first time kind of presenting over at pi
data i've attended the conferences
before in the past back in my home or
one of my hometowns of austin
uh
and uh
today i'm gonna talk about
like why i learned python in the first
place and then
how i'm using it today
and so
i learned i first picked up python like
around 11 years ago like iphone
2.2 2.3 so i've been there through like
the great python 2 to iphone 3 migration
and that was a hell hole
but python is kind of becoming this uh
more
common
uh
like interpreter language that we all
use a lot in our in our day to day and
the reason why is because you can kind
of turn these layman term objects into
something uh simple in code and it reads
somewhat similar to english but there's
some like weird funky things as we all
know in python
um and the chart i'm kind of showing you
comes from from back in the 80s and what
they were trying to demonstrate is that
all these languages that we create
whether it be code or something like
english um it's still inherently like
man-made
and so
in the past they they use like things
like fortran and basic and they
did all these like mathematical
functions and like wrote all the
mathematical notations into these codes
and then they also like
um you'll see in the old
chemical companies they were
writing like all the different notations
of chemistry as well like chemical
machine representation using these
languages
and at the same time
um
well this comes back from the 1800s and
now forward but iupac was developed so
we can call chemical compounds something
that uh kind of fit to like alpha
numeric like languages
and so
um but then what's happened in our
generation of millennials we
we like a lot of slang and we talk with
fast words and we type fast and uh
especially in the lab too we like to
talk fast and so the iupac nomenclature
we've kind of
turned it into what we call a preferred
name which i really think it's like
slang but
um we kind of have this formation of
like languages and python is now
installing itself as like
um
the main kind of uh
like vehicle that we can kind of like
communicate these languages to each
other
um
and so
i want to highlight like uh this is from
back in the day like 2005 like the old
python logo i think i found online and i
was like wow it
really iterated and from there there's a
lot of different other software all
involved but
um
into what this project really is
and so i want to start from
before i picked up code i was an organic
chemist and i spent a lot of years in
the lab
running reactions day after day and so
that's just what we like to do
the most prettiest thing i've ever seen
in the lab was is the thing on the right
um this came after the first step over
at my time md anderson
it created this beautiful orange color
so it just really shows you how
beautiful chemistry can be and so in my
mind you know the data and the way we
portray data should reflect the same way
as
something natural like this
um
so
uh what happened is that i quit my job
um
about a year and a half ago and decided
to go back to academia because i wanted
to go
i guess understand like chemistry a
little bit more in detail and see how i
can really apply it
so yeah i i went into the academia and i
came to baltimore
and it turns out
when i came to baltimore in january i
came across this
this group and
they develop like these force fields and
i'm like okay what what are force fields
um
and so i went into this long history
about what force fields are but uh
force fields are inherently like a way
to describe the movement of the atoms
and the geometry of atoms and
how and where and what position they're
going to be and
um
kind of demonstrating that flow and
there's like a series of numbers that
kind of like corresponds to all the
different atoms
now uh
there's different formulas that exist
uh in baltimore we have one of them the
name is called charm
um
and for this presentation you uh you
guys are all just going to believe that
ours is the correct one
because that's what i believe in so
uh
and what i'm showing you here is that um
when we try to like guess how these
atoms move in space
the
we try to guess like kind of a series of
numbers we do it manually
uh and you can see on the green dot how
many
manual numbers we kind of guess to kind
of like help predict like okay these
atoms move like this and these move like
this
and the red ones are determined from
like a calculation and so we categorize
all these different atoms and so we we
have like a series of elements if you
guys have all seen periodic table but
then we
we uh kind of
branch it out into like different
categories of these elements because
they're representing different scenarios
and in the bottom i'm showing you the
different classifications of what we use
as tunable things like bonds it's like
the spring constant and the spring is
something you guys all know from physics
right like one half kx squared looks
very similar to here right
so it's um
it's teaches basic
uh
force constants and these basic physics
that kind of govern all of this
the seventh term leonard jones i'll get
to um maybe a year from now
so
we we look at all these series of
numbers and we try to predict something
and then we tried to
figure out based on their atom scenario
and
what happened is is that i think
if i get the year right it's 2014
the they came up with a language to kind
of describe this and it and it
um
if you see what this language really
represents it's it's everything that
they've done with
the quantum mechanics state and
molecular mechanics data and all those
numbers and they've condensed it all
down into this language and they call
this language an atom type language so
you'll see a series of languages
accommodate different equations
and so we're looking at the charm
general force field language which is
depicted here on the left but to make
this represent back to something that's
chemistry
um
we actually have something here on the
far hand right hand side which is more
english like something that's just
alpha characters or something in that
series um this group of atoms like this
is how we were taught as undergrads and
so like we can understand a lot of
things that come from this because we
can use it to connect to other things
using casual inferences but to combine
these two languages together and to
create that type of language link we had
to go through a series of other
languages first
which is a little complicated but
luckily
um the
two
atom types uh connector was actually
already written here in baltimore by a
co-worker of mine the smallest of smarts
was written in python in london and the
smarts to iupac was written by me also
in python
and so python kind of served as a
vehicle to talk between these different
languages
um i actually used the sub process
around
this
locator right here so you could say it's
python
again
um
but then to
to make these connections we're going to
have a lot of different types of data
because if you think about it
a group
of atoms is just one name whereas like
each atom has like
you know a lot of uh
it depends on how many atoms are but
there's a lot of different names in
there so we're going to have a lot of
different type of data plus we also need
to understand what are we looking for
and what question we're trying to answer
um
in our
and and what we do um
when we when we start developing a force
field we have to do something called
parameterizing and parameterizing is
inherently like
sum it down to one word we're trying to
fix the force field and so we need to
know what to fix and so what we're
looking for is what to fix and so
to answer that question
um
my boss and i came up with a series of
different features we deemed would be
relevant to answer that question
question
the first would be like
what groups are in there and then the
second is what
different types of groups are in there
and then
there's these penalty scores and these
scores are telling you
what's wrong
the higher score is the more
uh
that thing
magnitude needs to be fixed
so
like uh we need to go after that first
because it's
a little bit more intense um
so this this penalty score uh
this is this is kind of a beautiful
architecture which you could always
apply to a lot of other things
um
so
this penalty score is what makes our
equation kind of unique because when we
guess something wrong
um we needed some sort of like a
feedback loop a feedback saying like
how
wrong did we actually guess this and
this penalty score is based off of um
something simple so
if
you
look at your file organization and you
say that like okay i'm going to a picnic
right and you take a lot of
um
pictures of the picnic and you do that
july 2019
and then
you have image one so dot j peg
and then
um you do another picnic
july 2020
and then you have another image
let's say that you
have another file you took another
picture
so
3.jpg
and then you want to place that file in
your
2020 over here
but it actually goes into 2019.
so there's
this is actually supposed to be with
2020.
now you research for your files again
and you don't find it
so every time you search through
something
that operation right there
is actually
a contribution to the penalty so it's
like an
inefficiency and so
we have these like series of numbers
that we deem as like if the organization
is bad or if it's like
um we've done too many operations of
some type of kind and like
it causes these different magnitudes of
the scale it produces this type of
penalty score
um
and
that to us is like what we feel is
if the atom types were organized
in accordance to whatever is the best
representation
then
theoretically
when we do collect all the atom types
the penalty scores of all of them should
be
zero
if we ever approach that type of scale
because then our organization of the
atoms be the best so we organize our
atoms in exactly this kind of way using
categories and subcategories
the penalty score though when you start
pushing it to an extreme we
you can just take that series of numbers
and take it as a list
and you just take the probability
density so where do the numbers like to
lie is what that's really saying
and you can do it associated with all
those different classifiers
and you find out that
they start creating these weird values
so the algorithm starts pushing into the
stream
like creates these weird valley networks
that maybe we can use to separate data
um and one of the ones i've done is is
over here at 150 and so what i said is
that what i noticed is that things above
150 tend to look a little bit more
complicated
um and maybe something interesting and
that's all i'm really saying
but i'm still trying to figure out if
that's true
um so that visual architecture you saw
before uh it
um
i want to talk about why i chose doing
sunbursting so the
the idea came from here
uh
my old mentor was a devops engineer and
he taught me a lot and he was like so
you're dealing with a lot of data and
i'm like yeah
i'm always full i don't know how to
organize any of my data and he's like
uh here i bought you this
and he bought me something called
daisydisk
and daisy this
i was like wow
it's actually really beautiful and i can
organize my data in such a way and see
where to look to go for things
and i
i looked into the history of what this
diagram really is and it's called sun
bursting
and then i looked up who
who does sunbursting in python
and then
plotly was the the main contender there
um
and so
partly had this way of just doing
interactive
sunbursting plots and i'm like okay if i
could ring the rig the plotly
and have it have the lexical keys that
i'm looking for
with different types of languages
i can make this work
um
and so
i'll show you it right here
so the first layer
is in correspondence with like the
different groups of data that's in there
and then
the second layer is the relations of the
groups
and then anything that's burnt orange if
you see
is considered
something that's 150 or above
and so that's where i'm saying that the
penalty score is really high and so if i
click
one layer deeper
it makes it a little bit easier on where
to click inside the data so i go deeper
in
i go deeper in
and now i know that a high cyclopropane
cyclopentane
and this atom type cg3rc1
is something that i should look into so
i should look into functional groups
that contain this atom type because they
tend to have something wrong with them
if i fix this they should stop burning
orange
um
and so
that's that's great you know i create a
plot and i have this information but how
do i now make this useful
um
and so i needed to come up with a way to
query the graph as well
and so i kind of came up with query
functions that accommodate these plotly
graphs and um
you can kind of see here it's just like
okay if i query
this was uh it was kind of bootlegged
and i was building it as i go pretty
quickly but i didn't know what filters
to add initially so um
the first ones i thought were like
anything high i would like
and then any functional groups
and then
later on we added filters of like the
weights and then the atom types and the
list of different atoms we'd be
interested in
and so here i'm pulling out a query of
this atom type in these functional
groups
and it responds with the penalty
as well as now their
organic chemistry depictions and so this
is a skeletal diagram this is how a lot
of
we're taught
in chemistry how to draw our our
molecules and how we can kind of talk to
each other about what's going on
um
and so we can get a lot of information
from just looking at this and so
uh
so now right
um we come up with this queries and
we start generating this list and so i i
needed to
to generate this list of things that are
um
interesting or things that i thought
what would be in so i could lead
clicking clicking through
and then selecting compounds um
and then one one week i went to my boss
and then i said um
pick one
and so
uh
i might open it up to the floor i don't
know if you guys can talk or you guys
can put it in the chat but
uh
i was wondering if you guys would like
to pick one or just say between a
through through h
i see more for h i see e
so uh
to move along i i actually picked e um
because i thought it was pretty
interesting and i thought it was like a
weird structure and kind of complicated
but
uh
f uh f you picked steven f which is why
my boss picked it um or he also picked
it can you give your reasons to why you
picked that
not really there's just sort of a get
feeling
yeah it's kind of a instinct right
that's uh
that's the hardest thing to code
um
usually uh when i deal with type of
slide it's
you kind of run off your instinct and so
that's what kind of separates between
machine and human but
um
he kind of told me his rationale and it
is a pretty interesting one it's
it has a rotatable bond a single line
right here and it's it's very like
separated and so you could like fragment
this like nicely plus this is kind of an
interesting simple thing if i look at
this this looks a little bit more
complicated i don't know what's going on
here there's like a lot of
you know letters and lines and numbers
and
um
you know this this kind of looks like
the most simple one out of out of a
bunch
so
uh
we chose that one and we decided to work
on it
um
and so
that's uh
that's kind of where uh i've i've ended
the
the talk for now um
and uh you can see here i've actually
tattooed one of the fragments to my arm
because uh i really enjoyed uh
parameterizing that compound and this is
something that's really dear to me
so in my spare time i
i've been doing this for years but i
write a lot of uh
chemistry to python packages so i i do a
lot write or i write a lot of rejects in
my spare time which is not
uh common amongst the newer coders and
so
i do that for string sub matching and
testing out 1d languages and so
um cocktail shaker i did that for
peptides and then
chemistry i tried to link smalls to
amino acids there's mold pdf i did the
smiles to pdf
and that's a kind of a weird way so
there's a lot of like weird and
interesting
python code that you guys can like play
around with and it's all open source
um and to kind of
end my talk uh
there's a lot of people that have given
me advice and so
um
alex kind of serves as my boss and he
has given me a lot of great advice on
how to
you know really make my
code useful to
to him and maybe perhaps the masses and
then a lot of people have helped me
along my journey in understanding
different components
um
diesel is the one that taught me about
uh
sun bursting and the sun juan here has
given me ways to like validate a lot of
my code
um
and then this guy pauline he really
knows how to manipulate numbers so
definitely someone to check out for but
uh yeah if you want for the last five
minutes i could walk you guys through
the code
if you want to see it
yeah we'll do that for uh
we'll do a few we'll do that for a few
minutes to see if anyone's just typing
up and then i'll uh
switch over because our next speaker
who's in here
yeah so i s uh this is the first uh
second version uh but i've moved on from
it
uh but i made it releasable for now the
initiates is like an object
and it's actually very simple
so
plotly likes to do things in ideas of
like four lists and then they map out
different lists with each other and so
it actually looks like something like
this
um
[Music]
where you have like a value one two
three
four
right or it could be like abcd and then
what we say is
actually i'll do a b c d
so let's do a list of a b c d and then
another list of e f
g h
this list we'd say is our parents
this list we say is our children
and it just goes by index order that
this is zero
zero parent
one child zero this parent this child
this one this one
if you wanted it to have like multiple
parents to one children
you would be like a b
d d
and then you'd say g and h are both
children of d and so you can kind of
just play around with this like
manipulation of lists
and so essentially the graph is just
four lists um
labels parents the values to the size of
it and then the colors
and so i create each list individually
so it goes through a series of data
mines which i call first layer second
layer third layer
and the fourth layer data mine and in
the end in the visualization you just
throw it in there labels parents values
and then the colors
and so the plot is actually a pretty
simple plot because they've got the
sunburst the the idea is just putting it
in their their data structure way i
like
was so angry with wrapping my head
around that initial concept first but
now that i have i think i understand
plotly in a very
beautiful way so it's my favorite
package um
yeah uh i i highly recommend plotli if
you guys ever want to create weird
interactive or
large data plots but yeah it's it's just
four lists
yeah thanks oh thanks for being a
speaker so like like the combination of
like programming and
in chemistry it's like you're touching
on concepts like i can't even barely
begin to verbalize
you enjoy the rest of the conference
thank you
all right
uh good guess stephen i mean you made it
through so on slide eight
you